the Senate Judiciary Committee's top
Democrat says the confirmation of
Supreme Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh
should be postponed
Senator Dianne Feinstein's the request
comes after the New Yorker published a
woman's claim that Cavanaugh exposed
himself to her during a drunken college
party
Deborah Ramirez acknowledged there are
significant gaps in her memories of the
evening but he is confident Cavanaugh
was there in a statement Cavanaugh says
this this alleged event from 35 years
ago did not happen this is a smear plain
and simple the story went online after
Christine bossy for to accuses Cavanaugh
of sexually assaulting her in high
school agreed to testify before the
Senate Judiciary Committee on Thursday
Cavanaugh also denies for its
allegations the New Yorkers chief
Washington correspondent Jane Mayer
co-wrote yesterday's article about
Cavanaugh's new accuser with Ronan
Farrow she joins us now from Washington
good morning Jane hi how are you good
read through your entire story The New
Yorker admits that they weren't unable
to confirm with other eyewitnesses that
Cavanaugh was even present at this party
why did you print this story we've got a
woman who was a classmate of his at Yale
who went on the record to describe her
own experience here and when we started
to do more reporting on it we found
another classmate who remembers hearing
about it that night or the next day we
compared the accounts of these two
people who have never spoken to each
other Deborah Ramirez and the person who
heard about it that night they were
identical they have all the same details
same location it seemed that there was
something to this we started checking
further and we found classmates had been
talking about this from for weeks and
months since July there been an email
chain of Yale classmates of of Cavanaugh
talking about will this thing come out
long before Christine Blasi Ford came
forward so we felt you know the public
ought to know about this the woman wants
to talk we felt this was important did
she want to talk or she only talked
after being contacted by the New Yorker
she spoke she didn't initiate this we
got in touch with her she thought it
over for six days as she sort of
searched her memories to try to make
sure she was confident of it and when
she felt she was and she retained an
attorney she said she wanted to talk to
us and tell her story and what she's
saying is quite forthright there that
she was inebriated that night as she
says was Kavanagh and the other kids
they were freshmen at Yale and she's
saying that she thinks the FBI needs to
come in and investigate this and she
says Jane that there are gaps in her
memory are you okay with her story
knowing she said that I was very drunk
that night and there are big gaps in my
memory you know the story is very
transparent about what she does and
doesn't remember but I so yes I am
absolutely 100% comfortable with the
story I've done a lot of reporting on it
talked to numerous other people and the
fact that Cavanaugh's friends who've
signed a letter for him are also the
people that she identifies as being in
the party it's not surprising really if
they don't want to say more they're
basically saying they don't remember
sorry James I get a certain point what
what's required they're things that
people won't say to a reporter that they
might feel they need to say to the FBI
that's why everybody thinks okay let's
get to the bottom of this okay here it
out III hear you on that Kellyanne
Conway was on our program earlier this
morning she says this is a left-wing
conspiracy plain and simple how do you
respond to that a smear campaign what
she always says
I don't know I mean you know there's
nobody who says including Brett
Cavanaugh's own the witnesses that the
White House and he sent for us to
interview I talked to them and I said is
politics motivating her
these were Cavanaugh's witnesses and
they said no maybe you know what can you
say Jane the corroborating witness which
you says has all the details including
Cavanaugh's name where did that witness
come from and where did that witness get
the
information about this from if that
person doesn't know Ramirez he remembers
it from from he was in the same dorm
same same little building on Yale's old
campus and he remembers it clearly I
asked him you know be very careful no I
said he heard it from someone who was
there and as I've said we interviewed
him and I said to him are you sure that
it was Brett Kavanaugh he said I am a
hundred percent sure but he admit he was
not at the party Jane let me ask you
this since your piece was published
yesterday - yeah have other women
contacted you
I barely had a minute - no no I haven't
heard from anybody else I've heard from
somebody else at Yale who's identified
the other people at the party and says
they that they were there but I haven't
had a chance to follow up yet okay I
don't think it's a woman got it okay
thanks so much Jane Mayer great to be
with you